make sure you let us know who you would
like to answer the question if you have
anybody particular in mind is that Rick
in the back yeah I've been a candidate
for the United States Congress I'm a
candidate for the United States Senate
here in Michigan I have been teaching
about Islam at every tea party at every
open event I get to no one else that I
know about not even Alan West beautiful
person that he is not even sui wonderful
person that she is that I
adore who else has the courage to openly
speak about Islam as has been taught
about this continent at this particular
place and why and this is to you paba
why is it that no other candidates that
no other politicians have the courage to
openly speak about this subject and the
threat that Islam is to this country as
well as to Canada as well as to Europe
as well as to the world why do they not
have have the courage to do what I do
and what you do well first I'd like to
say vote for
Rick just briefly politicians are
looking in the rearview mirror they are
absolutely not a reflection of what's
ahead uh the en media has been
completely co-opted the en media is
self-enforcing the Sharia they will not
offend they will not criticize Islam
they are vicious
when they don't like a candidate vicious
I mean did you see this week you see
Obama going after Romney
donors that's an incredible I mean I
don't want to get into a political
discussion here but my point is is that
we need brave men like you and we need
to support brave men like Rick and
that's the only way you're going to get
things done because if he gets legs if
Rick gets legs they're going to go after
him fiercely and viciously to destroy
him I mean when Sarah Palin mely tweeted
you know about the ground zero mosque
you know being a stab in the
heart they went I mean it was it was
vicious it was a tsunami of um of bad
media the only good thing is I think
that the American people increasingly do
not do not trust the media I mean they
see that the media is just uh completely
and utterly corrupt and in the case of
Obama criminally negligent in not
vetting that candidate that that was my
first book The post American
presidency I'm a director of act for
Canada which is act for America in
Toronto chapter new chapter but I'm also
director of no Islam and schools and we
have a mosquete in
Toronto um we've held uh demonstrations
on the steps of the Toronto School Board
uh We've held protests in the streets
first time the media came up and we got
good media
exposure second time
very few media except for Sun News
Michael Corin uh covered it uh after
that nothing tenant
Swindle how do we wake Canadians up and
how we can educate them because we're
going to use your resources and your
material because youve youve you've laid
the back open but what do we do now how
do we wake Canadians up Sun News is
doing a good job but not everybody
watches on
news and so we need to wake Canadians up
we can educate them but we got to wake
them up first well how are we going to
wake them up the only way you wake
Canadians up is to have a Canadian team
to win the Stanley
Cup you know it's not it's not look
you've got to remember that um and this
doesn't only apply to Islam this applies
to many of the Great issues social
issues such as marriage defending
marriage defending The Unborn most and
and I use the word um quite proudly most
normal people are raising their families
paying the bills being good citizens at
the end of a working day the last thing
they want to do is get involved
politically it's the um the strange ones
who go to the union meetings and and The
Fringe meetings I mean it is and and but
you know what they get things done so
let's not be too harsh on people who are
just exhausted at the end of their
working week however we have to be aware
and you know what's happening in the
west we're being killed with kindness
because even though we have this this
Rising tide of Islam which will not stop
it has no intention of stopping uh it
compromises is seen as
victory every every time we say let's
sit down and talk about this and maybe
we can work out a compromise they think
that they have
one people still have their very large
TV and their iPad and their iPod and
their their new car and their two
vacations and it's what Soulja nipson
was talking about so many years ago
don't you understand you fools you're
going to lose everything because you're
so comfortable so I don't really have
the direct answer I think you do it one
by one by one by one anything you can do
if you can broadcast broadcast if you
can blog you blog if you can speak to
someone in the office speak to someone
in the office personal witness uh not in
an aggressive way reach out to people
whenever you can please never be
frightened I mean we've gone past that
surely I mean really you can be if you
really think that if you just hide away
it will all be okay we've learned
throughout history that is never the
solution to any response to evil so
that's what I would say but but don't
think by some Grand gesture some Grand
campaign we can change everything think
it's going to be gradual just the way
shall we say the other side have won
things gradually we have to take them
back
gradually my question is for the
gentleman from Virginia um I come from a
city in Michigan that just built a
mosque last year but I didn't start
investigating Islam till just this past
February and I'm going back and looking
at the newspaper articles about it and
I'm seeing that the land was donated uh
they didn't mention the funding they
merged congregation with Nation of
Islam how do I
investigate where the funding came from
good the first thing I would do is find
some friendly
Realtors uh in in your on your side and
talk with them they have the expertise
they can explain what the records are
and how to read them and everything else
we rely heavily on people like Denise
Lee who's sitting here from Virginia who
understand is real
estate and um and then we have
auctioneers who call us and tell us that
hey we had some of those people at our
auction today uh and we also have school
Headmasters now who will call us and say
they were in here trying to buy my
school with cash they'll come in with a
big a big bag of cash and try and buy
the school outright um that's what you
do and then you learn it as you go
through it my background is in
investigative reporting and I did a lot
of of this so I understand some of it
but it's not that hard if the
politicians can learn it you can and and
you just do that you just compile
details and then go after them with it
when you have it now where you take it
it's hard uh the media as pamelo says
the media isn't interested there's
always something wrong with your story
you know and uh and I would take it I
would go on the blogs and do the things
and make sure Pamela knows about it
and and just go at them heavily but but
don't give up and just you know just
keep on them that that muscaria story
really came up through the internet
really came up through the blogs yes you
had media there the first time because
it went so viral and then it got quiet
so what I mean every time the left does
a rally or Islamic supremacists do a
rally they have five people there they
Triumph it they try it's a Triumph every
time even if it's just the mother and
the son and you have have to do the same
thing you're not going to hit a home run
every single time so what and you send
us the pictures this is the stuff that
we traffic and we traffic in the news
that the the media will not report yes a
a local conservative synagogue one of
the largest local conservative
synagogues invited Imam Mustafa El Turk
to speak on on the 10th anniversary of
911 they were told we protested some of
us were almost arrested the ADL who's
not our friend um I'm their number one e
yeah the ADL even on their own website
talk about talks about how anti-virulent
he is how anti-semitic he is and they
still let him in as a guest speaker on
the beima in in a conservative synagogue
you just have to get the word out it's
going on around here all the time and
distribute information that like that
widely in uh in Virginia we had we had
pictures of uh the the Headmaster at the
school and his family they go out every
weekend and take pictures of the bridge
supports of like the Chesapeake Bay
Bridge and a lot of the big Bridges and
the Maryland State Police got pictures
of them on the Chesapeake Bay Bridge and
we took that and we distributed it in
about a f mile radius around the
different things they were trying to do
different projects we have an
opportunity here in Michigan to take
what has been imparted by this heroic
panel to try to impress upon our
governor and our state uh Senate and our
state house that it's time in Michigan
because Michigan is one of the states in
play as Pamela has mentioned that has
been trying to pass two measures two
compatible measures to insulate that's
all we're seeking to do is to insulate
our constitution to protect it from the
encroachment undermining and eventual
evisceration by uh the imposition of
foreign laws so I urge you to contact I
have a sheet if you're interested to
contact um it's being held up actually
they're trying to choke it back in
committee but it's being very
courageously spearheaded by
representative Dave Aima and by Senator
Roger Khan they need our support I've
got the numbers there's going to be an
important conference you mentioned the
center for security policy the vice
president will be one of the panelists
at this forum I urge you all to become
engaged and again to take the
information that we've learned and to to
to catalyze it into meaningful and
effective action and I wanted to ask you
can you tell us about the itna camp aign
is taking place around the country to
try to um impede the efforts of states
that are trying to fight the imposition
of foreign
law a $3 million um uh billboard
campaign uh got Sharia you know Sharia
got questions get answers uh what we've
done is exactly that Islam ad that was
on uh Robert Muse's presentation I
didn't invent that ad okay the sun and
the grass and the trees I took their ad
come to Islam the exact same ad and flip
the language leaving Islam and so what I
did w was with with with um the Sharia
campaign Sharia got questions get
answers we did we mirrored the ad Sharia
um got got fatwa get answers uh call 1
1800 live free and if you called the
number 18888 live free if you call the
number Robert Spencer answered okay um
it's a it's a propaganda campaign now I
again it got media it me get getting
media is a way of getting the message
out we consider ourselves the work that
I do is like gorilla media that's what I
do I don't have $3 million I only bought
one city um but I yeah well you know but
Kansas City right across the right
across the street Sharia got questions
Sharia got fatwa you understand a little
inside baseball it torments them um um
but it also it also removes The Sting
from what they're doing this is what we
have to do you don't need a lot of money
and each one of you are your own oneman
media organizations you have email lists
you have friends you do things uh you
play tennis tily Winks I don't know what
normal people do I just work all the
time but you meet people and you talk to
people now you can't always reach
everybody there are people that are
married to their dog but last week we
were at Temple University uh Noni
Simon Robert uh Islamic apartheid week
and I will tell you it was a zoo if you
want to see what's going on it will
shock you to your to your core of what's
going on on college campuses it's
complete fascism I mean they came in
they took 75% of the seats the people
that really wanted to hear us speak
could not get in they were ridiculed and
made fun of by these protesters by these
fascists these Jack Boots and yet even
at the end a girl came up to me and said
I just want you to know I was here with
the opposition but I stayed and you you
fli me you turned me now what what this
girl is going to do in her life you you
don't understand your power you don't
understand your influence uh you there's
never going to be CBS News where you
reach millions of people but you throw
that Pebble in and you have no idea the
ripples how many people you reach you
know that whole program that it's really
it's an information operation program
what they're what they're trying to do
and and one of the with the the American
Freedom law and I'm I'm in an Arbor
Michigan here as well in fact I used to
be the senior counil at Thomas Moore for
12 years and I started up the American
Freedom Law Center with my colleague
David Yami who is truly the the expert
in this area and uh Frank Gaffney from
the center of security policy is on our
Advisory Board and one of the things
that he's done is I i' mentioned briefly
he created this this uh education
program a video education program so you
can be educated about truly what the
Muslim Brotherhood is about what Sharia
is about it's a video program we've got
to post it up on our website right now
the the first in our featured media uh
American Freedom law center.org so
that's a a a great resource for you to
be able to counter this information
operation that is uh that's going on
certainly the courts and and some
justices as we've seen in the Supreme
Court have been looking to international
law to make determinations but it our
constitution specifically has a
supremacy clause and in that supremacy
clause it makes the US Constitution the
supreme law of the land and so these
other other foreign laws cannot trump
our fundamental constitutional rights
should not trump our fundamental
constitutional rights but if remember uh
uh justice Ginsburg recently gave a uh
an interview when she was louing a uh
you know a foreign Constitution over the
Constitution South Africa so I mean
technically under our constitution it's
the supreme law of the land and these
other laws cannot Trump those rights but
uh depends on who the justices are and
uh elections have consequences in terms
of who's going to be on the bench so if
you have concerns about foreign laws you
ought to ensure that you uh you vote for
president who want to put uh justices on
the bench who are want to stick to our
US Constitution the text of the
Constitution and not look Beyond to
these foreign laws but it can't Trump a
a statute itself or anything else cannot
trump our constitution Supreme Law on
the
land thank you all so much for coming
don't waste what you have learned here
don't waste what you have heard here you
all are the soldiers in this battle as
Pamela always says whenever we're
speaking I hear her say this I'm going
to say it now this is a war that is not
going to be fought on battlefields this
is a war for our Justice our freedom and
for human rights it is a war not with
guns and bombs it is a war in our
communities and we are the soldiers it
is up to us I want to thank you all for
coming it was really thrilling you give
us all hope um Michael will be outside
signing his book for purchase yes
Michael um my books are outside if you
need any advice on something feel free
to come to us and remember if you're
working on something send it to the blog
we get it out there and we get it done
fight the great
fight